um no having swum along the english
channel rather than across it lewis pugh
is now taking on an
even tougher and chillier challenge
what is it he's joining us now from
hella in iceland hello to you
good morning kate how are you i am great
tell me what the plan is
so the plan is another 10 days of cold
water acclimatization here in iceland
slowly swimming in colder and colder and
colder water and then off to greenland
to
what i describe as the the epicenter of
the climate crisis and there i'll be
doing a swim across the face of the
lunar sat ice
uh it's the fastest moving glacier in
the world now
is this your biggest challenge yet
oh without a shadow of a doubt uh so
when for example when i swam across a
north pole in 2007 or on mount everest
in 2010 i was swimming a kilometer this
swim as a crow flies is 10 kilometers
and so each day i'm gonna do a kilometer
get out re-warm reheat and then get it
back in the next day
the thing about cold water swimming is
with most sports the more experience you
have the better you're able to do a
sport but with cold water swimming it's
a complete opposite and that is because
when you have been really really really
cold
you never forget it and so the next time
you get in the water you've got to get
rid of all those memories of the
absolute freezing cold which i still
have in my bones
is it
dangerous
yes without a shadow of a doubt it's
dangerous and the reason why i'm doing
this is to highlight the real speed of
the climate crisis i speak to political
and business leaders all over the world
i don't think
that they are on top of the there's a
speed of this of of this crisis uh i'm
asking leaders now to really join the
dots i'm going to this place where very
few people go to shine a light on what's
happening there i mean we have over 650
mps in the united kingdom hundreds of
peers i think about 20 members of
cabinet you ask how many of them have
been to illustrator been to greenland
have been to the polar regions
which you know is the epicenter of the
climate crisis how many of them have
been there and seen what's happening and
understand the impact that it's going to
have on all of us it's literally a
handful and so by going there doing the
swim
going there with sky news and showing
what's happening there we hope that
the leaders when they go to the cop
negotiations which is in just 82 days
time they'll all be meeting
in glasgow to collectively decide our
future and and they need to be informed
they need to be environmentally
illiterate why this particular ice field
uh though lewis why have you chosen this
spot
it's just because it's the fastest
moving it's moving at a speed of 30
meters a day i mean it's an astonishing
place the icebergs which are carving off
the alulasat uh glacier they're over a
kilometer tall i mean it's astonishing
imagine an iceberg coming off there
which is a kilometer tall legend has it
actually that the iceberg which sank the
titanic came off this glacier just over
a hundred years ago and as we all know
everybody said that the titanic was
unsinkable
the passengers on board there they were
asleep when that ship hit the titanic
and it's i think it's a good analogy
because uh i fear that many of our
leaders at the moment
are asleep at the wheel this is the
defining issue of our generation it's
the most serious thing what happens now
over the next 82 days
will define our future we have to get
serious about this crisis